Prime Minister is it not a sign of panic
that yourself and the West minister
leaders have come up here when it wasn't
even in the plan this week it's a sign
of how much the United Kingdom party's
conservative labour Liberal Democrat
care about this issue and care about
keeping our family of Nations together
of course it is an issue that will be
decided solely by the people of Scotland
but I want to make sure that they hear
how much the rest of the United Kingdom
also cares and wants to say to them very
clearly it's your decision but we want
you to stay doesn't it show something
though when the Prime Minister of the UK
greatbritain Long Island can't go out on
the streets of Scotland and make this
case as such a vital issue a store
occasion well I am out on the streets
and in people's businesses and you know
doing I've done everything I've been in
people's homes and I've done everything
you do in a campaign but I'm only part
of this campaign this is not a
conservative lead campaign it's a
campaign of all political parties and
people who have no allegiance to a
political party so there was a
suggestion that this was a campaign of
love bombing Scotland with your heart
you touched her own heart in that speech
downstairs but there was a lot of kind
of projects fear them as well maybe even
project terror talking about financial
services companies leaving the threat to
the pensions on your message is a bit
mixed on this promise it's a message of
both heart and head I think it's very
important for it to be really clear
about how passionately I care and other
people care right across our country
about keeping the united kingdom
together but i think it is also
important to examine what a cliff edge
this decision is i think sometimes alex
salmond wants people to think that
nothing really will change that it's a
vote in favor of Scotland whereas
actually it's a vote in favor of
separation and the argument I wanted to
make is that Scotland is a proud nation
and can remain a privation inside the
United Kingdom but it doesn't have to
leave the banking system the currency
the pension system but it does those
things if it goes independent but
prominence of the argument that seems to
be swaying core labour voters is if you
never want a conservative to rule over
you again then vote for independence and
they're right about that army well part
of the answer to that is to say if you
have
a no vote you get the boast of best of
both worlds because you have more
devolved powers here in Scotland so you
can determine your own health policy
your own education policy your own
taxation policy your own welfare policy
so to voters who say I want to choose my
own government I would say yes you can
choose your own government in Edinburgh
but while also being part of a united
kingdom that helps to keep you safer
helps to make our country stronger and
also makes all of us Scotland included
more prosperous nation why didn't you
put devo max on this referendum ballot
that was that was your call because I
think it's very important to ask the
prior question which is does Scotland
want to remain part of United Kingdom
right from the start of this campaign I
said that staying part of United Kingdom
meant further devolution what we've been
able to do during this campaign is to
see all of the parties offers and to
realize how close they are and so
therefore to set a timetable for further
devolution but in order to have further
devolution you have to stay part of the
United Kingdom if you leave the United
Kingdom that's the end of devolution
it's the start of total separation so
why not do it it back with that examined
on Sky knees I think a debate between me
and Alex Salmond wouldn't be the right
approach because this is a debate
between two visions for the future of
Scotland and it needs to be had between
as it has been add the leader of the No
campaign and the leader of the yes
campaign of course Alex Salmond wants a
debate with me because he wants a debate
between the First Minister of Scotland
and as he had put it a Tory from England
now of course that's a debate he wants
to have but it's not actually the debate
that's relevant to people in Scotland
who have to choose between two competing
visions of Scotland's future